can you tell the story of china from
1958 to 1962
what was called the great
leap forward orchestrated by chairman
mao zedong that led to the deaths of
tens of millions of people making it
arguably the largest famine in human
history
uh yes i mean it was uh you know a
terrible set of events um that led to
the death
you know people will dispute the numbers
um
you know 15 million 17 million
14 million 20 million people
uh died um
30 40 50 million some people will go
that high too that's right that's right
essentially mao
uh and the communist party leadership
but it was you know it was mostly mao's
doing
decided he wanted
you know to move the country into
communism
and part of the idea of that
you know was rivalry with the soviet
union
um you know mao was a good stalinist or
at least felt like stalin was the right
kind of
communist leader to have and he didn't
like khrushchev at all and he didn't
like what he thought were khrushchev's
reforms
and also khrushchev's pretensions
to moving the soviet union into
communism
so khrushchev you know started talking
about giving more power to the party
less power to the state and if you have
more power to the party versus the state
then you're moving into communism
quicker
so what mao decided to do was to engage
in this vast program
of you know building what were called
people's communes
and these communes
you know were enormous
conglomerations
of essentially collective farms
you know and what would happen on those
communes
is there would be you know there would
be places for people to eat and there
would be places for the kids to
be raised and you know essentially kind
of separate homes and they would be
schooled
everybody would turn over their metal
which was one of the actually turned out
to be terribly negative phenomenon
their metal pots and pans to be melted
to then make steel every of these big
communes would all have little steel
plants and they would build steel and
the whole
countryside would be transformed
well like many of these sort of i mean a
true megalomaniac
uh project
you know like some of stalin's projects
too
and this particular project then
you know the people had no choice
they were forced you know to do this
it was incredibly
dysfunctional
for chinese agriculture
um and ended up you know creating as you
mentioned a a terrible famine
that everybody understood was a famine
as a result of this i mean there were
some there were also some
problems of nature at the same time and
some flooding and bad weather and that
sort of thing but it was really a
man-made famine
and and and mal said at one point you
know who cares you know if you know
millions die it just doesn't matter
we've got millions more left i mean he
would periodically say things like this
that
showed that like stalin he had you know
total indifference you know to the fact
that people were dying in large numbers
it led again to cannibalism and to
terrible
wastage uh all over
uh the country and millions of people
died and there was just no stopping it
uh you know there were people in the
party who began to kind of edge
towards telling mile this wasn't a great
idea you know and that he should back
off but he wouldn't back off
and the result was
you know catastrophe in the countryside
and all these people dying and then they
you know compounding the problem was the
political elite
which then
you know if peasants would object or if
certain people would say no they'd beat
the hell out of them you know they would
beat people you know who didn't do what
they wanted them to do so it was a it
was really really um
a horrific
set of events uh on the chinese uh
the chinese countryside i mean
you know and people people wrote about
it i mean we we learned about it there
were people who were keeping track of
what was going on and eventually wrote
books about it so you know so we have
i mean we have pretty good documentation
not so much on the numbers numbers is
numbers are always a difficult problem
you know i'm i'm facing this problem by
the way this is a little a little bit
separate
with a hello de moore
where you know ukrainians are now
claiming eleven point five million
people died in holodomor
and you know most people assume it's
somewhere in the neighborhood of four
million
4.5 million maybe so you have wildly
different numbers
that come out and we have different
kinds of numbers as as you mentioned too
with the great leap forward so
it was a huge catastrophe for china and
now only backed off when he had to and
then you know revived a little bit
with the um you know red guards movement
later on when when you know he was
he was upset that the bureaucracy
was resisting him a little bit when it
came to the great leap but he had he had
to back off it was such a such a
terrible catastrophe so one of the
things about numbers is that you usually
talk about deaths
but with with the famine with starvation
the the thing i often think about that's
impossible to put into numbers is the
number of people
and the degree to which they were
suffering
you know the number of
days spent in suffering oh yeah right
now and so i mean death is
i i death is just one of the
consequences of suffering to me it feels
like
one two three years or months and then
years of of
of not having anything to eat
is worse and that's sort of those those
aren't put into numbers often that's
right and the effect on people long term
you know in terms of their mental health
in terms of their physical
uh health their ability to work all
those kinds of things you know i mean
ukrainians are working on
there are people working on this subject
now you know the long-term effect of
of the hunger famine on them and i'm
sure there's a similar kind of long-term
effect
on chinese peasantry of what happened
you know i mean you're destroying
multi-generational yes
multi-generational that's right that's
wow and you know it's a it's a really
you're absolutely right this is a
terrible terrible way to die
and uh and it lasts a long time and
sometimes you don't die you survive
but
you know in in the kind of shape where
you can't you can't do anything i mean
you can't you can't function
now your brain's been injured you know
um no no it's a really uh
these these famines are really horrible
you're right
you